on the outskirts of jakarta there was
nervous laughter and even a few tears as
these children became part of
indonesia's covert 19 vaccination drive
it was a little uncomfortable when the
needle pushed to my arm but after that i
felt ok
hundreds of students in greater jakarta
received their shots as the government's
campaign to vaccinate those in the 6 to
11 age group begins this week
i feel a bit more brave to go and meet
my friends now
when the delta variant spread through
indonesia from june to august the nation
experienced a surge in child deaths now
with the situation more under control
and vaccines available for children
parents say they feel reassured
i feel it is safer now it is like
preparing an umbrella for the rain
doctors say it is an important step in
making schools safer
the parents are very encouraging for
their children to get vaccination some
children are brave some cried but we
managed to vaccinate all these children
many countries in the asia pacific were
hit hard by the delta variant now in the
face of the omicron variant they are
trying to scale up their vaccination
drives the philippines is in the midst
of a second mass vaccination drive
people are now afraid of the virus so
they come here voluntarily
the philippine government wants to have
at least 54 million people vaccinated by
the end of the year among them children
aged between 12 to 17.
authorities in south korea meanwhile say
they have no choice but to reintroduce
restrictions after weeks of soaring
infections and calls from health workers
to ease pressure on overburdened
hospitals
we've seen a huge spike in the number of
daily new coveted cases but also we've
seen a significant increase in the
number of critically ill patients now
authorities say they will focus on
administering booster shots and
targeting the unvaccinated a similar
strategy for many countries in the
region jessica washington al jazeera
jakarta